the heading you made today was powers
and roots we've done powers okay now
this is the question that powers are the
answer to I want you to write down this
question with me this is the question
what do I get if I multiply a number
opinion we're seeing this right like 5
times 5 or 5 times 5 times 5 times 5 etc
that'll give you the answer right 5 ^ 4
625 let multiply repeatedly that's gonna
give the reason why powers and roots are
together is because roots are looking at
the same question from the other side
right roots are about asking rather than
what do I get if I multiply a number
repeatedly it's what number so I'd like
you to have these two questions written
down next to each other so you can see
the parallel what number do I multiply
repeat as many to get this right so I'll
give you an example
but can you see even by the wording how
these are the same questions phrased in
Reverse to each other okay so let's do
an example of powers we looked at this
before right v squared we said this
example what do I get if I multiplied
this repeatedly and 5 times 5 is 25
okay now this is the opposite it's what
number do I have to multiply repeatedly
in order to get for instance the square
root of 100 right so it would mean okay
there's some number
if I multiply it by itself something
times something I'll get a hundred
that's the answer so I'm going in
Reverse it's 10 right sir this is for
arm this is for squaring and for taking
the square root but we've looked at more
powers than just squaring right so for
instance if I said 4 cubed right that's
4 times 4 times 4 that's 64 okay so just
like you can take a square and you can
take the square root if you cube you can
take the cube root and there's a 3 there
to indicate I'm looking for the cube
root not the square root okay so the
cube root of 64 is what is that number
that if I multiply it by itself three
times I'll end up with 64 and of course
the answer is full okay all right let's
have a look at some trickier examples
how about let's see let's go with two to
the power of six now this is a bit of a
bigger number okay but we can do it
together it's not that neat right so the
power of 1 is to the power of 1 1 is
just 2 2 squared is 4 2 cubed a thousand
power 3 power of 4 16 power of 5 32
power of 6
okay now interesting same number I
wonder if you can see a connection there
by the way okay now but my point is just
like I took a square root just like I
took a cube root
I can take them or what do you think
it's cool if it's a six it's the like
ooh what shape is that well we're right
out of shape so we just call it the
sixth root this is the sixth root of 65
and it's equal to 2 because the number
you multiply by itself six times to get
64 is 2 now we've got the square root
here right well excels be calculator it
can do square roots for us as well if I
write square root 4 so I'm just gonna
okay now if I want to work out square
root it's a bit trickier because just
like with powers there's no square root
button on your keyboard okay
so there's a funny little shortcut for
it and it goes like this I kid you not
equals squat okay now another stamp you
squirt on Statesville square root if I
write equals square root and then I
supply a cell like b1 that's what we had
before
okay watch what happens let's give this
a go quickly
right and this is your her become I can
finish yours I don't you close your
laptop but I've got my you can see there
it recognizes square root I'm gonna
click on that cell up there can you see
that's what I've written yeah you've got
it it's up what's the square root of 1
what okay now just like before I'm gonna
copy it and then paste all the way
across now just look watch this now have
a look have a look all of these numbers
are awful there Missy it says 1.41 it
actually keeps going it's just this
excels run out of space right some
numbers are messy some numbers I'm nice
and neat which numbers are nice and me
too
three why why why is that what's special
about those numbers when I scratch it
I'll get exactly four when I squared
three I'll get exactly nine you know
what these other guys are asserts well
done